et maintenant oui je connais depuis
plusieurs années et j'ai parlé lui de
mon ouvrage génération erasmus
quand il était encore ministre peu connu
en europe et je crois que c'est un début
et c'est long il a été très bon à l'otan
et il a joué un rôle très important dans
les jt d'état aux mines qui était en jeu
c'est très très difficile
et pour nous qui nous étions présidence
et c'était encore plus difficile mais
emmanuel macron a joué un rôle très
constructive notamment vis-à-vis de
donald trump notamment vis-à-vis dans la
transe notamment vis-à-vis de la
question du changement climatique mais
aussi sur la question des migratoires et
je crois que la façon dont il a reçu et
ses dialogues exigeons qu'il a mené avec
poutine ça va tout à fait dans la bonne
direction donc vu des rangs mais vu de
ma respectives je suis tout à fait
satisfait et du début des manuels